what about Jimmy Kimmel oh no now it
gets a little bit trickier because Jimmy
Kimmel is a Hollywood celebrity he
spouts all the politically correct
leftist doctrines so he should get away
with it but maybe he went a little bit
too far because we now have shocking
breaking new evidence that Jimmy Kimmel
said the n-word now we already know that
he's worn blackface I guess technically
he's darkened his skin
he's portrayed black celebrities and
characters that is no longer acceptable
but then there's this album that Fox
News is reporting as an exclusive
breaking news audio audio gathered by
Fox News it's a it's a joke album in
which Jimmy Kimmel allegedly plays Snoop
Dogg and sings the n-word
[Music]
[Music]
what did you get me
okay so you get the idea this is from
Kevin and and bean this is an LA radio
group and they put out this album years
ago and the the key line there is fat
n-word in a sleigh giving gifts away and
here it's very much in the style of
Snoop Dogg especially from that era this
is not some amazing find this audio has
been on YouTube for years and the thing
that I find funny about this is this was
run news headline exclusive footage
Jimmy Kimmel says the n-word and then
they include the audio in there but they
bleep out the words oh I have no idea if
he actually said it or not I I guess I
take their word for it that they said it
but that that's the the kind of care
that it's the kind of walking on
eggshells that we have around this word
except only for certain people only for
certain people so what is it going to be
should Jimmy Kimmel be canceled this is
a question that conservatives are
debating right now because I think what
we all want to say is you shouldn't be
canceled for telling a joke you
shouldn't be canceled for saying a word
no matter how offensive the word is and
we should give comedians a little bit of
more leeway sure that's how I feel
it except that's what we've been saying
for years we let the left run roughshod
over us run roughshod over our culture
cancel the every single one of our
performers every one of our speakers
every one of our political commentators
every one of our politicians we let them
all do it and then we give them a lot of
grace and they don't learn the lesson
okay the whole the whole way that this
works of giving the left grace is if
they learn their lesson and realize that
we don't want to live in a society where
no one can say anything and everyone's
got to walk on eggshells and everyone
hates each other but if they don't learn
that if they just keep doing exactly
what they're doing then why would we why
would we hesitate seems to me the pros
of cancelling Jimmy Kimmel outweigh the
cons I don't I don't even I don't care
about Jimmy Kimmel I don't watch Jimmy
Kimmel he is the toast of Hollywood they
have him hosts all of their awards shows
but I think the pros outweigh the cons
right now he's on vacation which seems
like an excuse to me they'll probably
wait for this to blow over but there's a
chance that he gets canceled
[Music]
[Music]